chaque jour cette jeune femme passe
plusieurs heures devant un écran
le matin je prends mon téléphone cela
c'est la première fois que je vais très
bien je trouve que je fais parce que
j'ai toujours fait en fait depuis des
années
puis j'ai regardé réseaux sociaux je
regarde mes appuis je me dis oh ça va
être fait
mais finalement je tombe toujours sur
quelque chose une photos instagram ou un
profil facebook m'intéresse peu importe
plus comme on plonge répond plus
finalement c'est engager discussions on
pleure ça tombe sur quelque chose
d'autre snam a passé deux heures à mon
réveil
selon une étude près de 90 % des
canadiens de 18 à 30 ans consultent leur
téléphone intelligent avant même d'avoir
mis un pied hors du lit 40% d'entre eux
ressentent de l'anxiété
lorsqu'ils ne peuvent pas utiliser leur
appareil mobile assez présent
rosie xbox quatre téléphones tablettes
nintendo près de pandore express dès que
j'ai un moment je vais sur facebook
instagram au québec un jeune sur cinq
utiliserait de façon problématiques
internet selon l'organisation qui fait
la promotion de saines habitudes de vie
cap sanaa ça fait autant le beijing de
dd syrie qu'on écoute à travers une
lettre flic avant l'espère dépendance on
a une utilisation des fois qu'ils
excessive puis même si c'est un aperçu
ce pot et c'est pour récurrents et ça ne
devient pas ça fait pas des conséquences
ces vins est grande comme la pathologie
la sphère dépendance
mais avant ça ça peut quand même causé
des maux de dos des maux de tête
problèmes de vision au niveau de la
posture ça peut causer l'insomnie ce
qu'on appelle hyper connectivité ne
touche évidemment potes les jeunes une
enquête révèle qu'au moins une fois par
heure 66 % des canadiens jette un coup
d'oeil à leur cellulaire plus de 50 %
d'entre eux utilisent leur appareil dans
la salle de bain ces psychologues
précise que ce l'époque le temps
d'utilisation qui est un éducateur d'un
problème ça va avoir un effet sur la
famille sur les
relations sociales sur le travail
l'école puis on va voir aussi un
sentiment de détresse chez la personne
est en ligne et devant les écrans
ressentir bien apaisé mais si apple peut
y avoir accès à ce moment là c'est là on
va voir l'héritabilité des symptômes
dépressifs la tristesse ou de la colère
les experts recommandent de prendre du
recul et diminuer l'utilisation des
écrans au début ça me faisait un peu
paniqué j'ai le temps je trouve
notification pour que je réponde
après j'ai fait de belles la légende on
comprendre gens m'ont comprendront une
vie il faut la vivre sa vie peau
derrière son écran tout le temps elle a
maintenant plus de temps pour d'autres
loisirs comme la nature et l'amusé
le seul mérite
[Musique]